HOST: In East LA, this
would be a body shop.
In Balochistan, it's a beach,
an illegal chop shop for dhows.
HOST: But Razul's boats
don't go the whole distance.
The reason?
Dhows in the Indian Ocean
attract too much heat.
Western navies are now
fighting the war on drugs.
And, due to their
reputation for smuggling,
dhows are the prime target.
The 9,000 kilograms of
narcotics that we've taken off
the ocean would provide
a hit for each individual
in the United States.
The smugglers are very clever.
They learn how we operate.
We learn how they operate, and
the game is always changing.
HOST: With the
Navy on the prowl,
Razul offloads to other ships
in international waters.